بيتزا بسكويت معكرونه ايس كريم هذا هو
النظام الغذائي مو لي انا هذا الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن طبعا هذا هو نظام
الغذائي او نظام غذائي بالفعل يتسبب في
معركه مشاهدينا مستمره دائما مع زوجته
السيده الاولى جل
اللي طبعا عمره 80 عام هذا العام يكمل هذا
الرقم 80 عام ياكل كالطفل وفق ما نقلها
تقرير عن مساعدين في البيت الابيض وهذا
تقري
رنا بانه سعيد
ون اطباقه المفضله تشمل زبده الفول
السوداني والبيتزا والبسكويت والمعكرونه
بالزبده والصلصه الحمراء
والايس كريم عن جد انه يعني بدايه مش كثير
صحي لكن السيده الاولى تريد من بايدن ان
يكون بصحه جيده قبل الحمله الرئاسيه للعام
2024 حيث اتحث بعيدا على تناول المزيد من
الاسماك والخضروات الورقيه الامر اللي
مزعل الرئيس الامريكي
وهو ما يحب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات